ukraine has thrown global energy
supplies into crisis the uk and europe
are hurriedly assessing how to reduce
their reliance on russian gas after
sanctions were imposed on moscow
but president putin is fighting back
demanding that foreign buyers pay for
russian gas in rubles from tomorrow or
face having their supplies cut
while europe gets more than a third of
its gas supply from russia european
leaders are rejecting the demand so far
with germany calling it blackmail
we have looked at the contracts for the
gas supplies and other supplies and in
these it says that the payment will be
in euros sometimes in dollars but
usually in euros i made this clear in
the conversation with the russian
president that this will remain the case
and whatever his ideas are on this
subject and whatever will happen we'll
look at it very closely
but in any case the rule for companies
is that they can pay in euros if they
want to if they can and that they will
well our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter is here with me so
hannah what are the implications of this
russian threat well they're huge i mean
you heard there germany standing firm
but there are big implications vladimir
putin knows that europe is to a large
extent dependent on russian oil and
particularly gas
germany gets some 40 of its gas
from russia
so now the reality is that germany has
had to activate some emergency energy
management plans
the economics minister is asking
householders to think about the amount
of gas and energy that they are using i
mean the reality is that big industry in
germany would be the first to bear the
brunt of any shortages but we are
looking at the very real prospect if
vladimir putin follows through on these
on these threats of one of the world's
largest economies
rationing gas meanwhile as you say the
scramble to get off russian fossil fuel
very much continues that of course means
more renewable energy and finding
alternative suppliers but in many
european countries germany included it
might also mean burning more coal to
plug the gap interesting and i've got
another subject i want to ask you about
in just a moment because two shale gas
wells in lancashire which were due to be
sealed in june are now going to remain
open the fracking company quadriller has
been given an extra year to make its
case for shale gas extraction to boost
britain's energy supply so hannah what
does this move tell us does this mean
that fracking is still on well in 2019
the british government
banned fracking because it was worried
about the potential for seismic activity
for earthquakes and that risk hasn't
gone away unless cuadrilla manages to
prove otherwise as it certainly will try
to do
in the next 12 months but
a lot has changed as well since 2019
although the ban remains in place a lot
has changed of course russia has invaded
ukraine the price of oil and gas is sky
high and boris johnson is under
significant political pressure now from
a small group of very well organized and
loud mps who are saying that net zero
climate commitments aren't properly
thought through and that the prime
minister is falling short on domestic
fossil fuel extraction they want more
extraction than north sea they want more
of the fuel beneath our feet that's the
phrase
they are using now the official line
from number 10 will definitely be
cuadrilla simply applied for an
extension and got got one it's standard
practice but the reality is that
this extension has conveniently provided
number 10 with a decent amount of
wriggle room as it prepares to announce
the future of energy supply and security
in this country
hannah thanks very much indeed
well renewable energy bosses say they
can end the uk's dependency on gas for
electricity within five years
they've been meeting the prime minister
to discuss removing barriers to wind and
solar projects which would reduce the
country's vulnerability to huge
fluctuations in global gas prices and
help tackle climate change
but gas used for electricity is only
part of the uk's consumption of the
fossil fuel as our science and
technology editor tom clark reports
this is white lee near glasgow western
europe's largest onshore wind farm
if we're serious about weaning ourselves
off russian oil and gas the owner of
this project argues why not tap into far
more of the freely available energy
source that scotland has plenty of
we have 25
of europe's wind resource in scotland
honest to god we have to use it it's
absolutely criminal if we don't use that
and it's such a waste it doesn't matter
whether you're doing this to get to net
zero whether you're doing this to get a
more secure system or whether you're
doing this to get cheaper electricity
they all tell you the same thing build
build build do it fast
the renewables industry were at downing
streets to urge the prime minister to
remove barriers to onshore and offshore
wind as part of his energy security
strategy
done right they argue wind could replace
russian gas to generate electricity in
just five years
onshore wind turbines are now by far the
cheapest way of generating electricity
and they're some of the quickest to
build two
but these things alone aren't going to
get us out of the energy crisis
on and offshore wind farms and solar
power generate about 28 of our
electricity
nuclear another 16
but more than a third still comes from
gas
but that's just electricity look at our
overall energy consumption and the
majority a total of 73
still comes from oil and gas
in order to reach net zero there's
already plans to replace our 32 million
vehicles powered by petrol and diesel
and the 80 percent of our homes heated
by gas boilers but that's going to
require a lot more electricity
the switch to evs is happening and it's
starting to happen fast
and over time we're likely to have much
more electrified heating that is going
to put more pressure on our grid locally
and how it operates and that's a real
challenge that the government's got to
think through so that means we're going
to need more of that maybe nuclear power
or battery storage or something to fill
in on those days when the wind isn't
blowing it's likely that the electricity
system over the next 15 15 20 years is
likely to double in size which is going
to be an extraordinary difficult
achievement so we need a kind of all of
the above from clean technology
overhauling our energy sector will take
years so in the short term we'll
continue to rely on gas
and without measures to reduce demand
those high energy prices are here to
stay
tom clark sky news
now for some of the day's other climate
news and the environment secretary
george euster says today responded to
the news this week that the campbell oil
and gas fields license is to be extended
for another two years
we're very clear that we want to get to
net zero by 2050 and we're very clear
that we're going to significantly expand
our renewable energy contribution
particularly through offshore wind but
it's also the case that everybody
recognizes that there's a role for gas
during that transition
to a fully renewable future and in
particular some vehicles are going to
need probably hydrogen power uh to power
them things like buses and lorries and
so on and uh realistically during that
transition you will need some gas to
split the hydrogen from from that gas to
get what's called blue hydrogen and so
there's a role for gas during the
transition
from where we are now to the net zero
future we want to get to
the european commission has said it will
do whatever it takes to increase solar
energy equipment manufacturing the eu's
energy commissioner said the move to
rebuild the industry would allow europe
to cut reliance on russian gas
for the eu to achieve a climate neutral
economy by 2050 more than 80 percent of
its electricity will need to come from
renewable energy
and england's mountain hare population
could increase by restoring peatland a
study in the journal ecology and
evolution found that the number of hairs
found on restored peatland and bogs was
higher than on moorlands
conservationists say there are only 3
500 mountain hares left in england
carbon emissions in the uk are
increasing as the economy recovers from
the coronavirus crisis but they've yet
to reach pre-pandemic levels the latest
assessment by the department for
business energy and industrial strategy
found that greenhouse gas emissions rose
by 4.7
in 2021 compared to 2020 levels mainly
due to an increase in road usage now it
means that 424.5
million tons of carbon were released
into the atmosphere last year but that's
still lower than in 2019 when carbon
emissions were
554.8 million tons 5.2 percent more than
2021.
when you sow roads you harvest
traffic um and i think the welsh have
really worked it out thanks to their
climate change ministry and their their
world first piece world first
piece of legislation that all decisions
must consider future generations which
is something that's really weird that
westminster and washington and brussels
don't have but anyway they've decided to
put a halt on all new roads
if you look at the uk we have been
pumping out fossil fuels for far longer
than anyone else we've already used up
so much more of our budget than it's
currently um calculated for and our aims
to um
you know we might be
potentially on track for for carbon zero
by 2050 but if you really do the maths
properly um the leading lights and the
science of this area are are really
saying that the uk needs to be
decarbonizing significantly faster than
2050 so whilst it's always good to see
to see reductions in carbon emissions in
my view this
it's nowhere near fast enough
a new british polar ship has completed a
key series of tests on its maiden voyage
in antarctica the vessel named after sir
david attenborough will give scientists
cutting-edge facilities for studying the
oceans seafloor ice and atmosphere
the ship has completed 10 days of
testing showing it can break through ice
that's a meter thick at a speed of three
knots it's operated by the british
antarctic survey which says it will
transform how ship-based science is
conducted in polar regions
well joining us now to hear more is dr
andrew fleming a director at the british
antarctic survey welcome to you
so this trip was all about testing this
ship's capacity so tell us a little bit
about what you found and what the future
ambitions are for it
yeah so you're correct but our main task
during this period was to make sure that
the ship was
capable and matched its design to move
through sea ice as you described and
that was the that was the main threat so
we were looking for the right type of
ice and the right conditions to do those
tests and we were very pleased with the
results we're waiting for the final
analysis to come in but overall we're
very pleased some things to rectify in
the future but uh but it's all looking
good
that's that's good to hear give us an
idea though of how this will help polar
scientists in the future learn more
about ice and about climate change
the sir david attenborough ship is vital
it's a vital part of our um arsenal in
terms of understanding how the southern
ocean and the antarctic continent is
changing and understanding the impact
that that has on the on the wider world
so whatever happens in the antarctic
doesn't stay there it has an influence
and impact elsewhere so so david
attenborough the ship is bristling with
with scientific equipment and
capabilities and will
allow us to increase the range of
measurements that we take of the region
and therefore increase our and our
understanding of of the region and how
it's changing
and so when might that process start
well we've having completed this first
set of um trials and some of the science
has already started this this season
with and the deployment and recovering
of moorings that are already in the
antarctic um but having completed this
set of trials we now have a much greater
confidence in in the capabilities of the
ship and it's it's like taking delivery
of a new high-speed car high performance
car and that we're kind of now going to
make the adjustments and and tune it you
don't take it out onto the racetrack and
go flat out right from the get-go but
now that we understand how it handles
and how it performs a lot better and the
ship will now um complete its mission
down on the antarctic this season and
then head back up to the uk in the next
couple of months and there'll be some
work will take place
and some further trials but then next
year and next antarctic season
commencing later on this year will be
the first season of full
and science trials and we start to
exercise the full capabilities of the
vessel okay interesting stuff i know
you'll keep us up to date on all of that
dr andrew fleming thanks very much
indeed
no problem
to stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by chair of the chatham house
sustainability accelerator advisory
board bernice lee and the chairman and
founding director of the climate change
think tank e3g tomberg and we'll be
discussing if russia's demand to be paid
in rubles for gas will have an impact on
energy supplies to europe
[Music]
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
politically the two sides are as far
apart as ever and it's over that
question of who has sovereignty in
northern ireland the very issue that's
been the source of tension here for
generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy a
century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
bernice lee from chatham house and
chairman and founding director of the
climate change think tank e3g tom burke
good evening to both of you nice to see
you both
so first of all a standoff is brewing
vladimir putin has said that countries
who want russian gas must pay in rubles
germany said the announcement by the
russian president amounted to blackmail
a very difficult situation for western
countries who are promising to wean
themselves off russian fossil fuels but
can't quite yet
so tom first of all what do you think
the impact of this threat by russia will
be germany has said that it's going to
carry on paying for the gas at imports
from russia in euros as per its
contracts it says but do you think this
threat will make a difference to supply
uh
well it might make a difference to
supply it depends who's there's a poker
game going on uh mr president mr ruby
putin needs uh people to buy rubles in
order to prop up the value of the
ruble in russia and we need the gas and
it's now a question of who can
look the other in the eye and and call
the bluff in a sense my guess is that
this is just adding to the incentives
and the pressures for germany and the
rest of europe to get off russian gas as
it fast as it possibly can so my
instinct is there's be a real temptation
for them to call mr putin's bluff he's
going to find it very difficult to go on
financing uh his war if he loses the
kind of income that he's getting from
the gas so i i wish i knew the answer to
that because if you did you could win a
lot of money betting on it but i
honestly don't know
bernice what's your take on this i mean
these countries don't want to be paying
in rubles they don't want to be propping
up uh the russian economy so what are
their options some countries are really
dependent on russian gas aren't they can
they manage without it
i mean look obviously as tom said this
is a
brinksmanship game and obviously no
crystal ball but we also know that what
it really does do is to reinforce the
idea that it is important that we get
our russian guests as soon as possible
you know that in the uk for example heat
pumps and insulation would mean that we
could get off the impulse from russia
gas fire i think 2027
and so it is indeed possible for some
countries to actually get there
relatively quickly
but for others harder um tom i mean
some
will inevitably won't they think well
what's the alternative maybe the
alternative is increasing coal
production in fact i think that's
happened in some countries already do
you think that's the option they're
likely to take
i i think that is and i think quite
frankly that's a sensible thing to do in
the circumstances uh to do that i think
there'll be a lot of maneuvering going
and remember
we had in our own past periods when
during the coal miners strike uh in the
last century we men had to cut down our
industry uh to operating several days a
week instead of full time and i think
you'll see there are measures like that
that will help but yes and uh i think
we're going to go on
seeing a use of coal i think we'll see a
much greater that's the value of the eu
i think we'll see a much greater
cooperation between countries to try and
make sure that uh industries can go on
operating and homes can go on having
their lights
on and they're heating running uh but i
think there will be a real temptation
on the part of russia not to i'm part of
germany sorry not to blink and european
countries and actually to just take
emergency measures to see us through
what
may well be a move in the right
direction in any case bernice lee do you
think that the russian invasion will end
up with more fossil fuels being burned
in
europe
i think at the moment the worry is that
they will definitely lead to a blip
right now as tom said at the same time
the direction of travel in the longer
trip has never been clearer if we ever
needed a reason to get off it as quickly
as possible looking at the multiple
layers of blackmail it is now so it is
actually time to obviously focus back
efforts on scaling up renewable
improving efficiency improving
insulation all the things we know we can
do and we can do quicker too
okay let's move on to our next topic
which is not unrelated and that shadow
cast by the war in ukraine stretches
over here of course and renewable energy
bosses here say that their industry can
displace gas out of the uk's electricity
grid entirely in five years but then
that doesn't raise the question what
about transport what about industry as
well
realistically we'll need gas and all for
a very long time to come won't we tom i
mean first of all this thing that
they're they're talking about about
renewables replacing the need for gas as
far as electricity generation is
concerned within five years first of all
is that doable given that gas generates
more than a third of our electricity at
present
i i think it is doable uh to uh to get
gas out of electricity and remember in
any case the government just committed
to us having decarbonized our past
system by 2035
so that's just the kind of course we
were already on just accelerating that
course to take us down the thing that we
really need to do that would make that
even more possible is invest the money
the government promised in the uh
in its manifesto the nine billion pounds
for energy efficiency improvements which
it hasn't spent if we were to do that
we'd make it even more possible for us
to be confident that the renewable
industry could get gas out of
electricity in the time they're talking
about but the picture is much bigger
than that as i was uh hinting in the
introduction there bernice isn't it if
we look at our overall
energy consumption including industry
and transport the vast majority comes
from oil and gas doesn't it i mean we're
not going to phase that out anytime soon
well you know if you look at offshore
wind to be 11 gigawatts currently eight
and a half in pipeline three to four
years 40 gigawatt target by 2030. we do
a lot of the lifting electrification can
do of the lifting that we are talking
about so this is actually something that
we can invest more in looking forward to
as well
but but what about those who say isn't
the obvious thing to do bernice when
you're looking at replacing russian oil
and gas for example is to just drill
closer to home drill in the north sea
so the six oil fields that people are
talking about i think if three of them
would produce then probably they could
sort of replace the you know the impulse
already by about 20 i think i mentioned
earlier that heat pumps and insulation
can basically replace it by 2027 but if
they start producing the three out of
six they could produce is i think 2027
or something like that so in other words
even if they did it isn't actually and
full capacity would only reach by 2028
so it's not like even if you needed it
they could actually produce any faster
legislation could provide bernie say tom
burke we're out of time thank you both
very much indeed for your time this
evening
well that's all from today's show but
coming up sky's political editor beth
rigby speaks to the mayor of ukraine's
capital vitali klitschko on her new show
beth rigby interviews
that's coming up
but for me thanks for watching i'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you